herzlich willkommen zur pressekonferenz
nach der sitzung des csu parteivorstands
mit dem csu-vorsitzenden
ministerpräsident autor markus söder
unserem spitzenkandidaten für die
bundestagswahl alexander dobrindt und
generalsekretär markus blume herr doktor
söder bitte
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
das ergebnis von gestern abend ist ein
enttäuschendes ergebnis für die gesamte
union und ja es war eine niederlage
wenn man so viele stimmen verliert kann
man das nicht schönreden oder versuchen
um zu widmen ist war eine niederlage
dies gilt für die cdu das gilt aber auch
für die csu bei uns ist es so dass wir
an einigen stellen mit einem blauen auge
noch davon gekommen sind indem wir zum
einen die psychologischen grenzen 30
prozent und über fünf prozent geschafft
haben das reicht aber noch nicht aus das
was uns an der stelle erfreut hat und
deswegen auch noch meine gratulation und
dank an die wahlkämpfer fort wir haben
in deutschland das beste ergebnis was
die direktmandate bitte 45 von 46 dies
ist deswegen so bemerkenswert weil wir
in einigen teilen in deutschland kaum
mehr direktmandate für die union
gewonnen haben bei uns nur ein einziges
und das relativ knapp in münchen nicht
gewonnen wir haben aber in beiden
städten großstädten nürnberg und münchen
insgesamt sehr sehr starke ergebnisse
erzielt die csu ist jetzt lieber
alexander dobrindt auch ausdrücklich
gratulation an dich und aldi gruppe ist
jetzt nicht mehr ein fünftel soll ein
viertel der unionsfraktion und dass man
kann man sagen ja wir sind um 1 kleiner
geworden als csu landesgruppe aber in
der gemeinsamen fraktion größer und
haben deswegen auf eine gewisse
verantwortung
warum ist am schluss noch besser wurde
lag natürlich an einem schlussspurt der
insbesondere dem parteitag ausgelöst
wurde ich glaube dass das gesamte
ergebnis schlechter ausgefallen wäre
ohne unseren parteitag der parteitag hat
sehr geholfen zum einen und nochmal die
geschlossenheit von cdu csu zu
dokumentieren aber eben auch noch mal
ein klares thema mobilisierungs frage am
schluss in den mittelpunkt zu rücken ich
glaube dass ohne den parteitag es für
die stimmen für rot-grün am ende
gereicht hätte und die mobilisierung hat
dann an der stelle geholfen
nebenbei bemerkt auch die tatsache dass
bayern die höchste mobilisierung hat bei
der wahlbeteiligung hat übrigens dazu
geführt dass aldi um gerufen dass der
bundestag sich immens aufbläht eben
genau nicht erfüllt hat sondern im
gegenteil unser idee war richtig
trotzdem trotz dieser kleinen positiven
akzente bleibt der gesamteindruck
schlecht wir davon ist es nicht schön
reden und auch nicht zur tagesordnung
übergehen
es sind über 60 wahlkreise bundesweit
verloren wir sind bis auf baden
württemberg überall nur noch nummer zwei
im osten sogar nummer drei
dort sind weite teile ohne einen
cdu-direktkandidaten trägt können bei
den jungwählern nur vierte wahl und auch
bei frauen sogar über 60 hat man
verloren und was besonders schmerzt auch
die gesamtkompetenz werte waren
schlechter nicht nur in den themen die
für diese wahl eine große rolle gespielt
haben soziale gerechtigkeit klima
gerechtigkeit sondern einigen
kernbereichen die wirtschaft und
sicherheit was allerdings nach dem
afghanistan herausforderungen auch kein
großes wunder wahr und spürbar ist auch
ja es gibt und gab eine tendenz zum
wechseln deswegen ist jetzt wichtig dass
wir uns an der stelle noch einmal sehr
ernsthaft mit alldem auseinandersetzen
auch vor beiden heißt nicht zerreden
aber auf arbeiten heißt schon sich
ehrlich machen mit einer ehrlichen
analyse denn ansonsten kann man nicht
kraftvoll um gestärkt in die zukunft
sind
natürlich gab es keine zusatz boni durch
personen anders als zum beispiel in
mecklenburg vorpommern der wahl ist aber
ich sage ausdrücklich wir als csu wollen
keine rückspiele und keine zusatz kritik
üben alle haben fehler gemacht das ist
ganz klar
nicht jedes interview muss immer perfekt
und geglückt sein aber unter dem strich
jedenfalls ist es so dass das
gesamtergebnis nicht gut war und dass
wir uns damit auseinandersetzen müssen
jahr noch bei uns gab es die ein andere
personalfrage die den einern wähler
verunsichert hat ein zusatzeffekt tennis
bei uns gibt und den wir ehrlich gesagt
sehr intensiv bearbeiten müssen ist das
thema freie wähler die freien wähler
haben wir 4 prozent dazu gelegt und man
kann sagen am ende hat es möglicherweise
die bürgerliche mehrheit in deutschland
gekostet natürlich entscheiden die
freien wähler selbst ob sie kandidieren
das steht uns nicht zu das zu bewerten
aber der anspruch eine bürgerliche
mehrheit zu sichern ist durch dieses
engagement nichts hat nicht zu einer
folge für den gegenteil hinzu kommt
oder gesagt der tweet war ein
missgeschick ich weiß nicht ob das ein
missgeschick war
bei apartheid bei impfen bei klagen
immer wieder hören wir missgeschicke es
häufen sich jetzt die sogenannten
missgeschicke und ich war gestern erika
ein bisschen entsetzt das alles weil als
begründung für ihr wahlergebnis den
dritten weg die basis und die freien
wähler nannte deswegen meine dringende
bitte an die freien wähler jetzt auch
ich schätze überragende teil im kabinett
und ich schätze auch die fraktion sehr
und vor allem die vielen für den
kommunalpolitiker die in bayern eine
ganz wichtige und großartige arbeit
geleistet habe ich dann ganz viele freie
wähler landräte die gerade bei der
korona bekämpfung als manager vor ort
wirklich wichtige stützen waren und die
mitgeholfen und bayern gut zu beschützen
dass man nochmal in sich geht was die
dauerhafte kursbestimmung ist wir müssen
eine rückkehr zur sachpolitik finden und
können diesen art weg der die letzten
wochen war können auf dauer nicht
akzeptabel seien das ist dann auf dauer
eine auch innere belastung einer
regierung ist darf nichts sagen so
also das ergebnis ist nicht gut aber die
richtige analyse zeigt das war kein
rechtsruck es ist kein recht zurück wie
im jahr 2017 sondern wir haben in der
mitte verloren das heißt daran all
diejenigen überlegen was ist die
kursbestimmung der zukunft
modernisierung bleibt wichtig und
notwendig was uns in bayern schon
getroffen hat es muss man sagen
natürlich auch in eigenen an einigen
gegenden sind corona kollateral effekte
man kann es auch dort besonders sinn wo
die impfung nötig sind sind auch man die
stimmergebnisse könnte noch ausbaufähig
sein das ist wahr und da haben auch
sicher 23 prozent vielleicht verloren
aber das schutzgut sage ich ausdrücklich
cologne aber viel höher als
parteitaktischer wege um ende zumeist
recht machen kann einen klaren weg kam
in kronau was uns durch krone aber
meisten beschwerden als csu ist
dass wir unsere kampfkraft nicht auf die
straße bringen konnten denn diese nähe
durch verschiedene veranstaltungen
termine
bierzelt durch die liturgie des
bayerischen alltags von
neujahrsempfängen über stark befestigt
bierzelte bis hin zu den großen
volksfesten das ist sicherlich etwas was
uns gefehlt hat denn nur begegnung
schafft emotionen und hilft auch zu
erklären dort es ist zwar der erste
eindruck einer analyse was kommt jetzt
welche folgen müssen wir daraus ziehen
erstens für den bund
gestern sei es ja noch so aus als könnte
die union vielleicht noch den abstand
verkürzen oder auch vielleicht sogar
noch in einigen umfragen lagen wir
gleichauf jetzt ist das amtliche
endergebnis voller für ihr damit platz
zwei außerdem platz 2 ergibt sich kein
anspruch kein anspruch auf eine
regierungsbildung das sind können wir
nur ein angebot machen wir machen dieses
angebot in erster linie aus
verantwortung für das land wir glauben
dass eine regierungsbeteiligung und
führen durch die union für unser land
und die menschen mehr ertrag bringt und
besser wäre als das gegenteil aber wir
dürfen uns dabei nicht anbietern und es
darf sich auch nicht um endlosschleifen
handel mit endlosen verhandlungen
insbesondere deswegen weil entweder
herrscht eine innere bereitschaft für
einen neuaufbruch auch wenn einer
bürgerlichen regierung dann kann der
stadt finden oder es gibt nicht genügend
anvertrauen so dass uns nicht das
gleiche passieren sollte wir vor vier
jahren das dann eine regierung nach
wochenlangen verhandlungen dann doch
nicht zustande kommt jamaika ist dabei
tatsächlich eine option
natürlich wirtschafter für alle ein
spagat für die csu auch aber auch für
grüne für die fdp und jeder müsste aus
einer parteitaktischen nische oder
seiner komfortzone heraus aber ich sage
auch eine regierungsbeteiligung jamaika
kann nicht um jeden preis erfolgen das
sage ich ausdrücklich nicht um jeden
preis wir für uns als csu würden
eindeutig sagen dass wir zum beispiel
dann das soziale gewissen in einer
solchen konstellation unter anderem
werden wenn es um themen wie rente
pflege
wie auch umgekehrt die sorge um den
wohnraum geht wenn ich an wohngeld denke
und die soziale symmetrie den städten
wir stünden dabei ganz besonders für die
sicherheit die innere und die äußere
sicherheit wir würden klar machen dass
wir uns der ländliche raum zentrales so
dass wir nicht zulassen würden dass die
landwirtschaft nachteile bekommt oder
der ländliche raum kein ausgleich für
steigende spritpreise hat und wir würden
sehr klar auch darauf drängen keine
steuererhöhung und kein aufheben der
schuldenbremse
wir sind eher bereit auch uns
einzubringen als csu ich hoffe auch sehr
dass da nicht nur einzelgespräche
geführt wenn sie sich jetzt gerade
andeutet sondern miteinander geredet
wird aber ich sage auch die union müsste
in einem solchen
regierungsauftrag wirklich erkennbar
sein und sie darf sich nicht entfernen
ist ganz wichtig ja zur verantwortung
aber verantwortung bedeutet eben dass
wir an der stelle auch tatsächlich so
sehen das die union da ein
entscheidendes wort mitreden muss und
sprechen wird
parallel dazu zu der jetzigen sondierung
die stattfindet oder stattfinden wird
wenn es ja die nächsten tage sähen es
gibt bislang keine abstimmung über ein
format oder ein gesprächs kultur das ist
ja auch eine neue situation in
deutschland dass die denkbaren kleineren
koalitionspartner erst einmal reden
wollen um dann quasi gemeinsam zu
überlegen was sie den jeweils anderen
gegenüber stehen so eine spannende neue
konstellation wir werden sehen wie es
dann am ende ausgeht parallel dazu ist
aber mir wichtig und uns wichtig für das
erste habe ich übrigens den klaren
verhandlungsauftrag auch des csu
vorstandes genauso für das nächste jetzt
parallel ist für uns wichtig da auch
eine ernsthafte analyse noch mal zu
machen allein auch um die letzten
eineinhalb jahren nochmal aufzuarbeiten
und da werden wir uns viel zeit nehmen
auch ich als personen gerade diese basis
kontakte sind ganz entscheidend wir
werden nochmal eine wissenschaftliche
analyse auch über die entwicklung was
ist volkspartei wie ist volkspartei der
zukunft ausgestellt wie ist die balance
zwischen zukunft modernisierung und
tradition noch besser zu verbinden und
deswegen mit vielen regionalkonferenzen
das ganze auch dann diskutieren und
aufarbeiten auch wenn den
arbeitsgemeinschaften und das dritte
auch das sagen der stelle klar gesagt
sondern in berlin
parallel eine engere bindung in der
partei erzeugen und ist dritte
regierungshandeln in bayern voran zu
bringen
einige der themen die auf bundesebene
diskutiert werden müssen auch wir noch
mit besseren antworten versehen und zwar
entscheiden die konzepte liegen vor das
klimagesetz muss bald auf den weg
gebracht werden das thema schule und
kita muss verbessert werden es ist mir
ein ganz persönliches anliegen
der schule und kita ist für die
lebenswirklichkeit bayerns ein ganz
junges land als jünger werden das land
von ganz zentraler bedeutung wir müssen
den wohnungsbau beschleunigen um
insbesondere den städten für soziale
entspannung zu sorgen und die das
halbjährige warten auf eine klare
entscheidung für die alltags
digitalisierung darf nicht in den
zuständigkeiten verheddern muss dann
muss vorangebracht werden drei aufgaben
zusammen das bedeutet dann den komplexen
auftrag für uns den wir gemeinschaftlich
erfüllen wollen alles was wir jetzt tun
sowohl in berlin als auch in bayern
stellt die weichen für die landtagswahl
das ist wichtig dass wir jetzt sie es
uns da als großes team verstand sowie
die letzten wochen auch dies noch
verbreitern wollen mit allen ebenen und
dabei auch zeigen werden sollten wir in
eine regierungsbeteiligung dann dabei
sein dass die bayerische handschrift
sichtbar wird und dass unions konturen
sichtbar sein müssen es gibt nicht nur
um die frage wer bekommt welches amt es
muss man am ende sowieso noch mal alles
bewerten alle ergebnisse die jetzt waren
kommt es dann zu strukturieren sondern
es geht wirklich darauf was ist das
beste für das land und was hat auch ein
was hat auch eine rolle die für bayern
wichtig ist an der stelle so dass wir
nochmal zusammengefasst eine sehr ernste
zeit für die union
erneut geht am besten in der regierung
aber
nur wenn man da diese erneuerung auch
tatsächlich durchsetzen kann und nicht
wenn man quasi nur versucht jetzt
einfach zu erklären ich bin mit armin
laschet ständig in kontakt wir werden
versuchen so eng wie möglich uns
abzustimmen ist ein tagen klappt es war
dann spürbar gestern abend und wie
gesagt von meiner seite und es gibt es
keine rückspiele keinen groll ganz im
gegenteil wir sehen die ernsthaftigkeit
herausforderung aber wir müssen schon
einmal noch einmal aufarbeiten was war
denn französisch tauss hatte mir gesagt
noch schlimmer als ein schlechtes
wahlergebnis sind die falschen lehren
wie man daraus zieht vielen dank vielen
dank herr dobrindt bitter
ja sehr geehrte damen und herren das ist
ein sehr sehr schwieriges
wahlergebnis
und es ist ein wahlergebnis das
aus meiner sicht einer der unnötigsten
niederlagen der vergangenen jahrzehnten
bedeutet der schlussspurt der gut
funktioniert hat der hat nicht
ausgereicht um die spd einzuholen ich
will aber an der stelle allen danken die
im wahlkampf unterwegs waren die gerade
in diesem schlussspurt sich engagiert
haben allen kolleginnen und kollegen die
in ihren wahlkreisen gekämpft haben und
man hat auch da in den letzten wochen
gesehen dass der kampfgeist der
kandidatinnen und kandidaten
und insgesamt in der partei enorm war
die mobilisierung funktioniert hat aber
eben die spd nicht eingeholt werden
konnte
wir haben sehr deutlich das thema des
drohenden linksrutsches
formuliert wir haben offen gelegt wie
die strategie von spd grünen und
linkspartei an der stelle war dir dafür
geworben haben dass es dieses bündnis
gibt dieses bündnis hat jetzt keine
mehrheit auch das muss man deutlich
machen und deswegen gibt es verschiedene
optionen
und über diese verschiedenen optionen
die eine regierungskoalition bilden
können muss natürlich auch gesprochen
muss sondiert werden wir wollen das tun
wir haben ein entsprechendes angebot ja
auch unterbreitet und ich glaube es auch
notwendig gegenüber der öffentlichkeit
dass diese versuche der sondierungen
über die möglichen optionen unternommen
werden uns kommt dabei auch eine
wichtige rolle zu wir haben in der
fraktion
parteivorsitzender darauf hingewiesen an
relativen gewicht gewonnen die fraktion
insgesamt ist um
50 mandate kleiner
49 davon gehen im cdu teil ab einer
davon bei uns und daran sieht man dass
wir relativ größer in der gemeinsamen
fraktion sind unser anteil also in der
gemeinsamen fraktion größer ist damit
auch unser anteil an der inneren statik
größer wird und damit auch ein
erhebliches maß an verantwortung auf uns
an der stelle auch zukommt
die angebote zu gesprächen
die wir gestern formuliert heute nochmal
wiederholt haben das ist kein angebot
zur selbstaufgabe um auch das deutlich
zu sagen
wenn jetzt fdp und grüne miteinander
gespräche führen dann ist dies natürlich
möglich kann aber nicht dazu führen dass
man ausschließlich forderungen gegenüber
uns dann formuliert sondern es geht auch
darum
sondierungen die faire und natürlich auf
augenhöhe nur geführt werden können also
kein angebot zur selbstaufgabe kein
angebot zur inneren entkernung aber auch
keine absage an eine
verantwortungsübernahme um auch das
deutlich zu sagen
beides gilt wir gehen selbstbewusst in
solche sondierungen
wir werben dafür dass man diese
gespräche ergebnisoffen führt machen
aber auch sehr klar dass nicht unter
allen bedingungen diese
sondierungen zu einem positiven ergebnis
führen müssen also
verantwortungsübernahme ja selbst
aufgabe ein
wir haben sehr deutlich formuliert dass
wir uns vorstellen können dass dieses
bündnis
funktionsfähig gestaltet werden kann
reden dabei über
wirtschaftliche dynamik
das geht einher natürlich mit
entlastungen und finanzieller stabilität
klimaschutz ja mehr geschwindigkeit
dabei
sind wir dabei sicherheit ein zentrales
thema innere äußere sicherheit
bündnisverpflichtungen müssen in so
einer koalition eine große rolle spielen
können unter diesen bedingungen können
wir uns sehr gute zielführende gespräche
vorstellen klar ist dabei dass diese
gespräche nicht einer alleine führen
kann
auch keine partei alleine führen kann
aus der
cdu/csu parteienfamilie das geht nur
zusammen übrigens auch nicht nur
parteien sondern nur zusammen mit der
fraktion
und übrigens auch nicht auf einem langen
zeit auf einer langen zeitschiene das
müssen schnell die entscheidungen
getroffen werden das heißt innerhalb den
nächsten
kürzeren zeitabläufen also weniger
wochen muss die entscheidung dann fallen
wer abschließenden koalitionsgespräche
geht und wer nicht hier kann man sich
keine dauerhafte hängepartie leisten
da muss für die öffentlichkeit relativ
schnell klarheit geschaffen werden
markus blume bitte ja heute partei stand
sitzung nach einem ganz intensiven
wahlkampf und dann nach einem wahltag
das heißt auch natürlich bilanz ziehen
die diskussion heute im vorstand sie war
ja von der grundhaltung her demütig aber
eben auch einmütig demütig weil man erst
mal ehrlich und offen ein solches
ergebnis annehmen muss analysieren muss
auf sich wirken lassen muss aber auch
einmütig weil eben auch klar und sehr
homogen argumentiert wurde weil es eine
weitgehend identische grund wahrnehmung
gibt was zu diesem ergebnis geführt hat
aber mehr noch was jetzt zu tun ist im
weiteren wenn ich sage bilanz ziehen
dann heißt es natürlich auch auf den
wahlkampf noch mal schauen darf das
nochmal ergänzen und stark machen es
waren zwei elemente die am ende für die
csu auch nochmal an diesem wahlsonntag
entscheidend waren das eine war die
wahlkampagne der schlussspurt die
wahlkampagne der csu der wahlkampf hat
funktioniert ich kann mich noch erinnern
wie wir hier vor einigen wochen standen
und präsentiert haben dass wir uns mit
dem linksbündnis auseinandersetzen dass
es etwas was mobilisiert hat was
motiviert hat und am ende auch dazu
geführt hat dass wir bayern mobilisiert
haben die bundesweit höchste
wahlbeteiligung spricht hier tatsächlich
für sich es war tatsächlich so dass
dieses linksbündnis ja bis zur letzten
umfrage möglich gewesen wäre und das ist
jetzt am ende nicht mehr möglich würde
rechnerisch das ist auch ein erfolg den
wir für uns verbuchen möchten neben der
wahlkampagne ist entscheidend dass der
wahlkampf vor ort funktioniert und ich
darf mich den dank von alexander
dobrindt anschließen darf mich auch bei
ihm bedanken also mit seinem
spitzenkandidaten wie auch bei den
parteivorsitzenden wir hatten einen
unheimlich starken engagierten wahlkampf
vor ort bei unseren kandidaten und ja
wir sind schon stolz darauf dass wir das
flächendeckung prinzip für die csu
weiterhin hoch gehalten haben und zwar
nicht nur im flachen land sondern eben
auch weitgehend in den großen städten
viele hatten hier die csu in den letzten
wochen schon abgeschrieben und dass sich
unsere kandidaten mit hohem einsatz vor
zurückgekämpft haben und bis auf eine
wahlkreis alle wahlkreise in bayern
gewinnen konnten zeigt dass wir auch
unser partei motto näher menschen bei
dieser wahl einlösen konnten neben dem
thema sondieren in berlin geht es
natürlich auch um konsolidierenden
bayern markus söder hat es genannt wir
werden uns mit der analyse zu befassen
haben wissenschaftlich abgestützt aber
wir werden auch uns in bayern versammeln
müssen in der partei um neue kraft zu
sammeln um neue stärke zu sammeln für
die anstehenden aufgaben der gehört
sicherlich das thema basis tour dazu
gehört das thema dialog dazu das sind
alles dinge die wir schmerzlich vermisst
haben fakt ist ein digital wahlkampf und
es war der digitales der wahlkampf in
unserer geschichte ein digital wahlkampf
ist am ende eben doch einen distanz
wahlkampf und eines transfer kampf kann
die präsenz und die naehe nie komplett
ersetzen das hat unterm strich
sicherlich auch stimmen und zum teil
stimmung gekostet und deswegen wollen
wir mehr präsenz herstellen so weit das
schritt für schritt auch möglich wird
und wollen eben auch einen
diskussionsprozess einen dialog prozess
mit der partei staaten aber auch mit dem
gesamten sogenannten vorpolitischen raum
weil wir sehen dass hier in den letzten
anderthalb jahren vieles brach lag brach
liegen musste aber jetzt der zeitpunkt
ist wo man sich da sozusagen auch neue
einwurzeln kann
vielen dank die erste frage kommt von
uli bachmeier von der augsburger
allgemeinen
ja ich habe zwei fragen zum einen hören
wir aus dem vorstand das zum teil sehr
scharfe kritik an armin laschet geübt
wurde das ist dass einige zum zweiten
würde ich gerne wissen wie sie das jetzt
mit den freien wählern weiter sehen sie
haben die ärgernisse
aufgezählt daher am vormittag gesagt es
gehört zum tagesgeschäft dass man jetzt
wieder zur tagesordnung übergeht und
alles andere über wahlkampf wie sehen
sie das perspektivisch
also zum ersten kann ich nicht sagen
weil ich es generell zu halten dass ich
als vorstand sind so nicht sagen aber
wir haben hier insgesamt glaube ich
haben wir eine große gemeinsame
gemeinsame bereitschaft zu gemeinsamer
verantwortung auch in einer möglichen
neuen regierung gezeigt immer den
bewegungen die wir gehen an das zweite
ich weiß wirklich so einfach ist einfach
so dass wahlkampf und das war's jetzt
hat wir haben auf jeden fall größeren
gesprächsbedarf und ich weiß auch dass
es bei den freien wählern selber
gesprächsbedarf gibt denn es bleibt ja
da sacharbeit liegen schauen sie als
letzte in die entscheidung nicht für die
fluthilfe abstimmen zu können das ist
gute recht eines koalitionspartners das
zu fordern aber dass reiht sich an
irgendwelche
ständigen klagen anzudrohen auf
bundesebene die dann auch immer
scheitern bis hin zu manche wortwahl als
wir müssen einfach mal reden und
sozusagen gewissen hygiene prozess auf
den weg bringen und diesmal bereden denn
auch da gilt der grundsatz man muss
jetzt dass alles was da war auch mal
aufarbeiten so einfach ist es jedenfalls
nicht und das muss ich mal gesprochen
werden und zwar intensiv dann auch mit
verbindlichen festlegungen für die
zukunft
timo frasch von der faz
zwei fragen also auch nochmal armin
laschet betreffen würden sie denn sagen
er ist derjenige der für die cdu und für
die union federführend jetzt die
sondierungsgespräche überhaupt noch
führen sollte führen kann hat er dazu
nach dem wahlergebnis die kraft und
halten sie es momentan für möglich dass
wenn diese gespräche zu etwas führen
sollten also zu einer jamaika-koalition
dass armin laschet der nächste
bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik sein
könnte also erst mal die gespräche führt
nicht einer es kann gar nicht sein
es ist auch zum beispiel es reicht auch
nicht auch dass eine telefoniert sondern
es muss tatsächlich auf breiter front
und drei der basis diskutiert dazu
können parteivorsitzende
fraktionsvorsitzende oder
landesgruppenchef dazugehört
generalsekretäre und vielleicht noch ein
weiterer kreis er muss nicht zu groß
sein aber da geht es schon in solchen
schwierigen zeiten die verantwortung
breiter zu schultern das design und das
zweite mal am arsch etwa der kanzler
kandidat selbst zu sich gestern ihren
regierungsauftrag oder ein angebots
auftrag noch einmal reklamiert und ich
habe das gestern auch unterstützt
christoph trost dpa
da würde ich dann nochmal anschließend
also dass sie haben gestern ja noch
etwas offensiver gesagt sie gegen mit
dem ziel in die gespräche in
sondierungsgesprächen klaren führung
auftrag für flasche zu definieren warum
sind sie halt defensive weil der sket
was größeres zwischen spd und union wenn
man sich in der bevölkerung umhört dann
ist ja schon so dass man sieht die spd
liegt vorne anderthalb punkte plus -
vor der union und zweitens gab es auch
in den vorjahren wundern immer eine
klare kanzlerpräferenz für olaf scholz
das heißt fürchten sie dann nicht
sozusagen ein rückschlag in umfragen ein
folgewirkungen wenn jetzt die union
sozusagen den unbeliebten
kanzlerkandidaten zum kanzler küren
sollte auf biegen und brechen danke also
der unterschied zu 20 15 gestern haben
es tatsächlich das ergebnis deutlichere
klarheit gebracht hat also gestern abend
gab es hier noch umfragen gerade bei der
ard da war noch fast von einem
gleichstand die rede jetzt hat sich dann
durchgesetzt dass ihm die spd schon
vorne liegt das ist jetzt auch nicht
weltbewegend der vorsprung also
angesichts der ankündigung und
selbsteinschätzung der spd ist kein welt
bewegen der unterschied das muss man
auch sagen auch wenn man die mandat im
bundestag veranstalter sind nicht sehr
viele trotzdem muss man das anerkennen
den platz eins der parteien hat die spd
an der stelle national gewonnen und
deswegen auch heute auf meiner sicht man
kann bei minus acht prozent nicht von
einem geborenen auftrag sprechen das
wäre echt vermessen und man sollte ein
solches wahlergebnis auch mit der
gebotenen demut annehmen
muss schon auch ein wahlergebnis
respektieren denn die leute haben damit
eine aussage getroffen die menschen die
muss sich auch wieder finden übrigens
auch wenn in der programmatik tiefe
und das zweite ist dann bei der frage
wie es dann weitergeht
ich hoffe halt sehr dass wir also wir
haben natürlich eine aufgabe denn man
darf nicht vergessen nahezu gleichstand
spd leicht vorne aber die umfragen sind
ist eine dann würde ich mich an vielen
stellen leichter tun ist wenn es nur
nach umfragen geht aber im endeffekt
zählt das wahlergebnis und das ist die
basis für alles und es muss eine
mehrheit im parlament gefunden werden
ich halte es nicht für ausgemacht dass
das so ganz einfach wird mit mit der
ampel
die grünen müssen halt jetzt auch für
sich selber überlegen wo ihr weg hingeht
das ist doch ganz klar wenn man bei den
grünen die auffassung dominiert dass sie
am ende sich wohler fühlen bleibt bei
hand borjans bei bei frau essen bei hans
kiener dann ist das eine entscheidung
haben wir zu respektieren
aber dann haben die grünen nicht mehr
das den anspruch wirklich bürgerliche
politik und partei sein zu wollen und
das müssen sie halt letztlich auch
entscheiden da gibt sachfragen aber ich
glaube es ist auch so eine
grundüberzeugung die man entscheiden was
das ist eine richtungsentscheidung ampel
oder jamaika ist eine
richtungsentscheidung deswegen muss das
jeder für sich an einmal selber bewerten
wir werden über details wie ebenso
wieder alexis gesagt hat aber ich hätte
ihm ich könnte mir vorstellen dass man
in jamaika einen aufbruch definiert und
nicht nur ein gegenseitiges
stillhalteabkommen wie es vielleicht
eine ampel der fall ist aber das müssen
die beteiligten parteien wissen und ich
finde auch muss ich noch mal sagen es
ist zumindest ein neuer vorgang dass
zwei kleinere partner in einer solchen
regierung dann vorher quasi sich
besprechen und dann eine art casting
wettbewerb machen welche der beiden
spitzenvertreter besser wäre also ich
hoffe einfach sehr dass das von einer
hohen ernsthaftigkeit und seriosität von
allen seiten getragen ist bei uns ist
der fall er vom bayerischen rundfunk
bitte
wenn sie in im dialog mit ihrer basis
feststellen dass die iren
modernisierungs und ökologie kurs nicht
gut finden wären sie da bereit ihre
politik auch dementsprechend der basis
anzupassen
schauen sie wenn die mehrzahl der bayern
in bayern trennt ihres hauses das als
das wichtigste thema erachtet das
wichtigste thema dann muss eine partei
die die mehrheit repräsentieren will und
für sich selber einen führungsanspruch
ableitet dann muss sie dies auch zu
ihrem anliegen machen zwar nicht nur
technisch sondern auch innerlich ich
glaube dass das schon ganz wichtig ist
dass man gerade auch was das themen
management betrifft noch mal wirklich
genau überlegen muss ob die leute uns
dass überall auch so abnehmen also ich
glaube an meine persönlichen engagement
für klimaschutz gibt es auch seit meiner
zeit als umweltminister wo ich
spannende diskussion um den donauausbau
hatte einige waren da schon dabei damals
oder um dialog gentechnik oder ähnliches
mehr ich habe da auch
haltungen auch niederlagen eingesteckt
es gilt übrigens gleich wie beim thema
frauenquote wir müssen immer die balance
halten zwischen beiden aber gewählt wird
man auf dauer nur wenn man auch in
zukunft anspruch definiert das bewahren
allein hat schon strauß gesagt ist nicht
die zukunft allein aber dass wir noch
mehr vielleicht erklären können erklären
müssen das ist überhaupt kein thema aber
die wahrheit ist ich glaube das sieht
man ja auch ein bisschen faul ich sie
jetzt gerade nicht was gott verdeckt
werden ja ihre schuld wenn
sie mal auch so die persönlichen
zustimmungswerte sehen können immer noch
besseren höher sein aber die zeigen
schon dass ein großer teil der bayern
genau das auch für richtig empfindet
also für mich ist es wichtig dass wir in
diesen zeiten die sich scheinbar
schneller drehen als früher
geschwindigkeit halten und schritt
halten vielleicht sogar voraus kommen
zwischen dem was die bürgerinnen bürger
als ihre themen finden und dass parteien
zu definieren ist ein anspruchsvoller
prozess vor allem der mann mehr haben
will als acht neun oder zehn prozent und
der anspruch den haben wir den nämlich
auch weiter war aber wichtig ist auch
das kann ich ihnen auch ganz persönlich
sagen es fehlen halt diese
für mich zum beispiel sehr wichtig sind
ja also bierzelte sind nicht alles aber
sie sind teil der politischen
kommunikation in bayern viele sitzungen
vor ort sind nicht alles man kann sie
ihre virtuell machen aber ist ein
unterschied wenn man sich nochmal direkt
sieht denn eben begegnung schafft eine
andere form von emotionen verständnis
und all diese dinge sind durch krone
einfach reduziert an das kanalnetz und
es war auch des corona ist ja auch wenn
wir den schutzauftrag wirklich bestens
erfüllt haben das können sie sehen zb 1
2 wahlergebnissen in
bereichen wo impfquote nicht so sind
gibt es ja auch zusammenhänge wo man die
beschwer richtig spürt auch da geht's
halt weiter daran zu arbeiten und wir
die basis zu verbreitern
anspruchsvolle aufgabe zeit intensiv
aber
spannend und lohne
so jetzt hier hinten nach im winter vom
bayerischen rundfunk
also da es gab vor dieser sitzung auch
vereinzelt den wunsch die csu müsse sich
personell an der spitze etwas breiter
aufstellen wollen sie diesem wunsch
entsprechen also aus der partei heraus
wohlgemerkt und an sie herr dobrindt die
frage mit welchem plan gehen sie denn
morgen in die fraktionssitzung in berlin
und zwar über ihre eigene wiederwahl die
sie ja wahrscheinlich anstreben hinaus
können sie sagen wie die landesgruppe
rein gehen sollte in die wahl der
fraktionsspitze dankeschön
also ich denke ich wäre sogar alexander
doppeln vorschlagen das ist
normalerweise
nicht privileg sondern auch keine bürde
natürlich sondern das gewohnheitsrecht
des vorsitzenden das wäre ja auch tun
weil ich überzeugt dass alexander
dobrindt in dieser ganz schwere phase
ganz zentraler baustein auch für die csu
es muss ich ausdrücklich sagen nicht nur
weil jetzt gut zusammenarbeiten sondern
weil auch ein hohes maß an kompetenz und
cleverness besteht und sollte es
tatsächlich zu einer
regierungsbeteiligung kommen mit jamaika
dann wird es auch von seiten der csu
eine menge menge an arbeit und
cleverness erfolgen sich da gut
aufzustellen und ist zweite wir haben so
viel stellvertreter wie nie wir haben so
viele mandatsträger natürlich ist es
ganz klar wir stellen uns immer bereit
ist möglich auf jeder hat den freiraum
und als team müssen wir uns stark
aufstellen entscheidend ist aber immer
dass wir da die wichtige wie in jeder
fußballmannschaft verstehen sie es
braucht insgesamt teamgeist und team
charakter den hammer aber heute auch gut
gezeigt bisher dafür
was die fraktionssitzung anbelangt dass
erst das ist die wichtigste aufgabe dass
wir die fraktionsgemeinschaft
beschließen zwischen cdu und csu das
muss ja nach jeder wahl immer wieder
erneut erfolgen
wir werden das erst mittags bei der
landesgruppe tun und dann in der
gemeinsamen fraktion zumindest gehe ich
davon aus dass das passiert danach gilt
es die geschäftsordnung der fraktion zu
beschließen und dann die frage des
vorsitzenden ich gehe davon aus dass wir
über diese frage entscheiden werden
morgen aber dass eine entscheidung
trifft die fraktion dann vor ort aber
ich halte es für richtig dass eine
entscheidung über die fraktionsführung
über den die fraktionsvorsitzenden
getroffen wird und dann wird man bis
dahin sehen was an
diskussionen heute abend morgen
vormittag entsteht bekanntlich wird ja
immer viel gesprochen auch zwischen den
einzelnen
landsmannschaften der fraktion aber da
ist noch ein bisschen was zu diskutieren
aber die entscheidung wird glaube ich
der fall
alexander kein passauer neue presse
also da
sie haben jetzt gesagt was alles gut
läuft haben auch ansagen gemacht für die
möglicherweise anstehenden
sondierungsgespräche haben sie eine idee
was falsch gelaufen ist in diesem
wahlkampf weil außer bierzelt am freien
wählern habe ich dazu nicht viel gehört
was der kurs war es die kampagne war es
der kandidat das haben gesagt sie wollen
offen darüber reden aber sie macht muss
nicht mehr
wo wir diesen internen sehr offen
darüber und haben das glaube ich auch
einige sehr deutlich angesprochen ich
habe versucht in diesem ganzen wahlkampf
so viel gemeinsamkeit zu betonen wie es
geht wenn dies immer nicht
hundertprozentig geklappt hat oder x
oder mein interview bisserl besser oder
schlechter kontrolliert war dann dann
mag das sein dann tut es einfach leid
aber im großen und ganzen glaube ich
haben wir uns wirklich mühe gegeben
gerade am schluss noch einmal zuzulegen
und dieser schlussspurt das glaube ich
akzeptiert jeder auch national war ein
wichtiger beitrag um überhaupt in diese
option position ins gerade zu kommen
und alles andere muss man's mal in der
ruhigen analyse aufarbeiten
ich sehe keine weiteren fragen dann
letzte frage noch unikat man ja noch mal
es wird der analyse ist es super
stichwort seit der landtagswahl 2008
wurden immer wurden uns immer
umfassender analysen versprochen die
herz dann nie gegeben können sie in
zeitpunkt nennen wann sieht es auch
öffentlich kommunizieren ja relativ bald
also das wird wir müssen schauen dass
wir das parallel zu den sondierungen
organisieren also was nicht sein wird es
wird nicht sein dass man sortiert und
nicht regiert in bayern
also dass man monatelang sah das
finnische regierungssitzung start ist
egal und wenn man dann am sonntag
regieren oder gehen am sonntag
regierungsmitglieder müssen ihre und um
die uhr im einsatz sein gibt da keine
freizeiten und das zweite genauso
organisieren der parallel dem prozess
muss jetzt in den nächsten wochen
stattfinden und ich stelle mir das sofa
ist eine wissenschaftliche analyse
machen diese gesamten befunde jetzt auch
zusammenfassen das was wir jetzt aus
diesem unzähligen charts haben auch an
den
aus den wahlergebnissen ist aber auf
bayern natürlich fokussiert und daraus
dann natürlich diesen regional prozess
ab bleiben und der soll mit größeren
regionalkonferenzen in der
verschlossenen türen mit einer sehr
offenen aussprache das war schon im
parteivorstand wenn man gar nicht so
leicht weil da jedoch viele von ihnen
live beteiligt sind und es gut
mitverfolgen können
stattfinden und parallel dazu wird auch
der generalsekretär noch einen prozess
in den kreisverbänden staaten also jetzt
schon jetzt
maximal
maximal gesprächs intensität für alle
beteiligten und da muss auch jeder jeder
sozusagen sein einsatz noch einmal
deutlich verdoppeln und welche das noch
ergänzen darf einfach mal nach der
landtagswahl hat ist natürlich
stattgefunden also da kann ja ernsthaft
keiner sagen dass da einfach das motiv
weiter so sondern wir hatten ganz
grundlegende prozesse mit parteireform
eindrücklichen parteitagen und auch
einem kurs und inhaltliche veränderungen
zwangen sie den einen oder anderen dann
begeistert haben und in einer anderen
noch
begeistern lassen müssen dürfen
aber es ist so so war es ja logisch
wertvoller prozessor war es der
ausgeglichene haushalt von für die für
die erfahrenen unter ihnen sind ja die
meisten sind ja sehr sehr jung welcher
see
der ausgeglichene haushalt den wir heute
alle so loben und preisen die damals
dabei waren wissen dass das war eine der
schwersten zahlen geboten die die csu
ihre geschichte hier hatte ja also das
sind alles im rückblick erscheinen die
prozesse noch glorreicher als im moment
ihrer entstehung wirken so ist es
vielen dank und bis bald keinen tag noch
gern wieder danke